thank you guys very much for coming this
has actually been a workshop that Julie
and I was just leaving but you're
welcome to say hi he's the organizer of
this event where and I came up with this
workshop about say a year ago when we
worked together I thought it would be
awesome to have to have you guys come
over and learn just like the basics just
like have an end to end kind of run with
machine learning basically do get the
data clean it up extract some features
train a model test it deploy it it's
gonna be awesome so that's actually
seeing this idea materialize today is
awesome so thank you guys very much for
coming
just a quick just so I'll know you guys
better how many of you have some
experience with the Python written by
Khan code awesome analytics how many of
you have held analytics jobs right great
so just a quick introduction my name is
Edith Kohli
I'm a data scientist I'm a team leader
at big a bit at big of it what we
basically do is we help huge brands
usually game companies and app
developers to acquire new users and
retarget old users so basically if
you're if you want to acquire new users
in the in the country that you're
working in or you want to expand to a
different region so basically what we do
is we use machine learning to segment
the audience and target and help you
guys understand and target those like
the users that will be of high value to
you that's in a few words what big a bit
does so the agenda for today what we're
gonna talk about what we're gonna talk
about is it's basically what is machine
learning 101 so what is machine learning
and when we need it
we're gonna get into the difference
between classical programming and
machine learning
and basically why you leave it
generic machine learning workflow so
basically how does how do you go about
doing this machine learning thing the
steps of machine learning so this is
like a breakdown the workflow so we're
going to get into each and every one of
these each eye is going to take over on
the feature engineering part and then
we're gonna get to work this is why this
is the reason you guys came here so what
is the chin wearing and why we need it
so basically machine learning is a
subfield of AI it's it's basically you
wanna you want to give the computer to
learn and improve from experience
without being explicitly programmed what
does that mean in classical programming
what we do is we put in data and grooves
and we get answers an example of that
would be if some number is greater than
15 we'll do that right else return
something in machine learning we had
kind of flipped the process what you do
is you get data you get answers and you
get you put in data and answers and you
extract rules so there's that how does
how much program a classical in a
classical scenario a program that would
tell you whether or not a picture is a
picture of a banana or not like that
that's a little bit more difficult than
saying whether or not a number is
greater than 15 right you've got to put
in a bunch of photos and you got to tell
the computer this is a banana and
eventually the computer is going to
figure out the set of rules that make a
picture beat a picture of a banana so
it's going to find some pixels and it's
going to say the dominant color is this
and is going to say the edges are a bit
curvy this is extremely difficult in the
classical programming scenario and this
is why machine learning was invented in
the first place
so the proq the problem that we've
talked about now is a problem of
classification we want to say whether or
not something is a banana or not but the
realm of machine learning is much
greater than that
so in machine learning we have I tried
this picture tries to capture the whole
thing but it just but it captures a
glimpse of it so basically what we have
is this realm over here of unsupervised
learning
basically what unsupervised learning
means is that we don't know the correct
answer we have a lot of data we can tell
you something about we have features
from the data basically we have rows and
columns we can have many rows and many
columns describing something but we
don't know exactly what this thing is so
what we want to do is we want to maybe
cluster together rows that are similar
or that are close in the in the
Euclidean space an example of that would
be grouping together of documents so
basically if you have a whole bunch of
documents and you know the text of them
and you want to group them together say
these documents all are medical
documents and these are all legal and
these are all whatever so basically you
use unsupervised learning to do that and
then you can be saving a lot of human
effort to tag everything because you
have all these you just tagged a little
bit and then you say all of these are
close together so you can extract a lot
of information from that the other
scenario is supervised yeah still yeah
so the thing is yeah but you don't have
to classify the whole thing yeah you
just have to classify a sample and then
say which ones are closer together right
the other realm over here is
reinforcement learning there's a field
that had gained a lot of momentum lately
alphago you guys know alphago yeah beat
the world champion it go a super
complicated game so what is
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is learning by just having the
computer not giving him not giving it
any data just letting him figure out for
itself like a baby you said like we call
it an agent send an agent to the world
that makes mistakes that it learns from
its own mistakes
random stuff so it bumps into a wall and
then it figures out that there's a wall
there and it can't go through so an
iRobot would be a good example of
something that explores the space and
then figures out for itself and iRobot
doesn't have a data set of the room that
it cleans right it just figures it out
for itself and the last but not least
this is the most I reckon popular field
of machine learning this is what we're
gonna do today
it's called supervised learning
supervised learning meaning you have a
data set and you have the answers and
you want to figure out the rules all
right so an example of that would be the
Titanic competition that we're going to
do today so basically we're going to
classify whether or not a person had
survived the crash of the Titanic or
didn't and we're going to do that by
examining the patterns that emerge from
the data so we have all the people on
the ship and how much they pay for the
fare and what class were they in and
what floor and the ship were they in and
then we're going to figure out whether
or not they survived another type of
supervised learning is regression so
basically if we all we want to purchase
a house say and the house has this in
this many bathrooms and this is as many
bedrooms and it's located here and there
we can use this data to estimate the
price it's not a 1 in a 0 it's not a
classification but it's a price it's
continuous so we're going to say this
house is going to cost I don't know half
a million dollars a hundred thousand and
we're gonna give rough estimates of how
how much the house is gonna is going to
cost us that's the output of a
regression test and this is where we're
going to be today where the arrow points
classification as I said the Titanic so
let's try to kind of describe in broad
brushstrokes the generic ml workflow so
you get a date you get a data set we're
going to talk about data collection in a
bit would you collect data and then you
have a data set that's rows and features
and then you prep the data what do you
mean prep the data you prep the data for
analysis you make sure the data is clean
you make sure that all the features are
transformed and are in scale you make
sure you extract features that might be
meaningful to the task at hand and then
you go to training the model then
basically you build a model you use a
train and a test set
so you input this data in and you input
the answers as well and then you go to
the testing part you see how well do you
do if the model only said this guy's
gonna survive the Titanic but most of
them didn't it's not going to be a great
model right it's it's worse than random
guessing so this this is an iterative
process you train and test and you train
and test eventually you get a good model
then when you have a good model you
deploy it and have some system serve it
for example you have a recommendation
system and you work at Netflix you want
to be able to deploy the model in to
bake it into the product itself for it
to actually generate recommendations in
real time right so this is inference
actually doing the inference after you
have baked the model into the product is
the final stage then it's a loop then
you get data and you train it again and
you deploy it
that's what data scientists doing that
we're real-world so let's talk a bit
about data collection and how important
that is so basically there's a saying in
the machine learning world it's garbage
in garbage out and it couldn't be any
more true basically a model is think of
a model as a thing an entity that only
views the world through the data it's
given all right so it's not like you and
I that we know we see a picture of a
banana and say aiya this is this bananas
a bit weird I don't know why it maybe
has a lot of black spots it's more it's
uh I don't know or it's like greener
than a regular banana it doesn't have
that when you tell them all that this is
a banana its world composes of that
banana so it's going to classify weird
bananas as bananas and
and regular bananas is not bananas right
so how what data goes into the model is
almost is the most important thing in
machine learning basically everybody's
going to talk about modeling and they're
going to talk about deep learning but
actually what goes in what features go
in is the most important thing another
thing to pay attention to and this the
the realm of statistics deals with this
a lot is what am I not seeing so the
data coming in might be might be
collected from say a pole right they
call you up election day who are you
gonna vote who are you gonna vote for
and most of you 95% 99% just hanging up
the phone or say this is not convenient
or I don't want to answer but the people
who do answer polls might be biased in
some ways right they give answers and
you go ahead and analyze those answers
as if you've gotten them randomly from
the population but they might be biased
towards people that tend to answer polls
maybe they're older maybe they're
younger maybe they're more female more
male I don't know so biases by seizing
the in the realm of machine learning and
garbage in garbage out is the key
takeaway from this it's extremely
important to pay attention to what
you're not seeing and make sure your
data accurately represents the problem
so talk a little bit about data QA and
this is this is a topic that's that's
too often overlooked by saying garbage
in garbage out this is basically what I
mean this is like a drill down many
times you see in datasets things that
things that cannot exist right you see I
gave here an example that the state is
New York in the city the city's Los
Angeles this this doesn't make any sense
this data point is corrupt and like we
said earlier the model and in in big of
in the scenario in big of it we see a
lot of maybe we might see someone that
installed the app but did not click the
end which makes no sense you got to
click and then you have to install so
basically
showing the model this it would not
question your data this is this is its
world this is what it knows and if you
put in something like that you got to be
super careful to filter out things that
are nonsensical in your data otherwise
your model is going to mess up its
predictions the other part of data QA
statistical QA and this part is a bit
more subtle so basically in every job
interview every scenario in which you
are tested or compared to someone else
people would evaluate you on your
ability to question everything right
you've you're given a data set don't
believe it it might be filled with lies
and models trained on that might be
performing worse than random because
it's filled with biases and it's filled
with things you've got a sieve out in
order for the model to work correctly so
basically let's let's take this example
you've got to be suspicious of over
representation of the population of
Chicago right this wouldn't be this
wouldn't come up in a scenario in which
it's not it's not nonsensical I mean it
makes sense that Chicago would be great
would be if I don't know bigger than Los
Angeles in this data set but you got to
ask yourself why why is my data biased
towards people from Chicago why am I
getting more data from there this might
bias your your data set in ways that
might go back and bite you later
now each eye is going to take the take
the floor and talk about future
engineering I work in the optimum human
in optimal Q would predict the
availability of users of customers so
that the organization can call the
people who are available and that will
of course eventually will
improve their answer rate and the
conversion rate okay so we were on the
step that you had the data you collected
the data
you made all the keyway and cleaning and
now you want to build the model and use
the data so the first step I'm going to
talk about is feature engineering and
feature engineering before we talk about
what is feature engineering it just make
sure that everybody understand what the
feature is so a feature is a single
metric that goes into the model as an
input as you can see the output is it's
your survival survival but we have both
features so generated feature edges the
picture went to the feature in this
example this is only a matter of balance
and page so feature engineering it's
actually a process where we modify the
input of code into the model okay we add
feature we subtract which will change
modify the features in order to get
better performance of the model some
people would say that this is much more
important than their actual algorithm
that you use and this is very important
I mean you can take any data set and
just be the model you get in a
performance but normally without
fidgeting in will get good performance
now where do we get the features from
okay what is the source of the features
so first of all it's for our data okay
you can take a single picture and we can
modify it and change it we can you know
make some rational people pursue an
example also things like
more than one feature from our data
let's say we take two features where one
is a start date and then we have an end
date and when we can have the duration
as a new feature and of course we can
bring new information from other sources
if we feel that our data is lacking is
not bringing us any good performance and
as IDO said earlier you know machine
learning is a iterative process and once
we came up with with the feature we
cannot you know just collect a bunch of
features and boom try them on the model
we need to verify that the feature that
we are creating is is good enough so
basically what we do we generate a
feature and then we evaluate it on the
model and if we see that it is you know
it improves the model then we can update
the model and and carry on because not
every feature that we generate is is
good for the model any questions so far
[Music]
you test them okay you come up with the
feature and you evaluate it okay we talk
about
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah you look at the results
you look at we'll talk about metrics in
a moment but you're trying to see on the
test set what kind of performance
improves your performance you want we
talked about it in in the next two
slides because you wanna test your model
on new data okay and we talked about
test set and Train Set and how to to
combine them like you can always find
there's always a story you can find
Mike's great and shoe size because it
has kids six so some features that may
be disturbing because okay
sometimes you can have a good feature
but if you have for example another
feature that is correlated with the
first feature they will not work
together okay
so a lot of thing is just to try and
test okay I don't know if I understand
the distinct question but you know
sometimes a feature that you generated
will not work well but only with another
feature both of them will give you
resulting let's see some examples for
future engineering this is really a
small some small examples because it's
it's a very vast field here so the first
is the categorical features categorical
features are features that are not
numeric features okay they come in
category for example we have a feature
here you know name color and the
categories are red yellow and green so
what we do normally is we use one hot
encoding that does anybody know they
were not encoding okay what what one hot
encoding what we do here is we take each
one of the categories in the original
feature again we generate for each one
of them new feature so if we had the
categories red yellow and green so now
we had we have new features red yellow
and green
each one of them gets its own feature
and we get we we have one okay for the
for the right row number okay you
instead of three columns you want one
two three because you know the model
gets numbers that's what the model knows
and when you give it numbers so 3 is
greater than 2 2 is greater than 1 but
that's not the case with with colors I
mean red is not greater than then being
the yellow for example okay so you you
can give it sometimes it's possible when
you have for example if you have
ages okay you have a child you have an
adult and you have an old man so in that
case you can do that okay so this is one
example another example is timestamp
features when you get timestamp time
centers includes the you know the year
demands the date the hour and everything
so you can extract a lot of information
from that you extract the the day of the
month the day of the week the hour a lot
of things as we talked to before okay if
you have two timestamps you can have the
the duration you can have trends
arithmetic operations everything that
you can imagine subtraction
multiplication and everything another
example is bucketing or classification
like we had the example that we have
here on the right hand side no it is
it's not a feature it is something that
you apply in order to get new new
feature okay on a feature or on a set of
features okay so a bucketing you know
some models will we take pocketing
better than I know an original column an
original feature so for example age okay
this is the example that we have here so
instead of age we have buckets of ranges
lower range a middle and high range
another example is text analysis
sometimes you will have in addition to
numeric features you will have some text
feature let's say for example comments
and you would extract you know some
inside some words and phrases that you
have in the comment in order to create a
new feature and the last example here is
called dimensionality reduction and this
is something that we use in order to get
fewer fewer features for example if you
have a vector of
let's say ten numbers and then you have
for each number a feature then you can
use them internally to reduction in
order to squash it into you know two
three four features we're not going to
talk about it too much but models with
limited number of rows of data they
don't like to be very complex so they
move the the multi complex the more
complex the model is the less
performance we get okay so this is
dimensionality reduction any questions
about engineering if you take it the
marketers for marketing I will change
the processing it may need to bias
results may be it
it can happen okay but it very depends
on the data it depends on the model okay
[Music]
any numeric feature that you can it
doesn't always work okay but this is
something that you can try okay now a
few words about splitting training test
we talked about how to do it in a while
but let's say what why we do it normally
we take our data set and we split it
into train and test but what would
happen if we let our algorithm learn our
data
okay the full data okay as we can see
here and then we take out the label
and we asked the model to predict the
same data you think that I will get good
performance yes of course we'll get a
very good performance because our model
already knows all the samples you know
that for the first sample let's get zero
and then it would be it won't be a
problem but what would happen if we get
it relative to predict a new data yeah I
think it's very tempting to say that the
performance will not be good but
actually we don't know okay because we
haven't evaluated it correctly so what
we do basically is split our data into
train tests sorry transit and test set
and the model learns on the train set
and evaluates we evaluate it on a test
set where the test set is basically
where piece represents new data ok data
that the model doesn't know and more a
bit more sophisticated way is to split
it into three sets Train Set evaluation
set and tested where the model learned
on the train set and we check it on the
evaluation set for example if we add a
new feature as we talked before we will
examine it on the evaluation set why do
we do that we do that because we don't
want the model okay to see too often the
test set because we want to leave the
test set as something that ok represents
new data okay and of course in addition
there is something called
cross-validation where we use the test
set not-not-not
as you know something fixed but we
change it within the data just the size
of the Train the duration
which is which there are some there are
some best practices okay
but normally depends on the data if you
have a lot of data okay you will okay
explain the test because normally you
want to have a lot of Train Set okay
because you want to learn cross
validation across validation is when you
take your data set and you split it into
a few folds for example four folds
okay and then each one of the folds is
actually serves as a test set on its
turn so you learn on the three parts
okay three parts you make the test and
then you test it on that part and then
you change it so this way you can test
all all of your data the reason that we
do that is that we don't know if the
test set is it's not about the accuracy
it's about the variance okay because I
don't want to get into too too much into
it but the test set is just just
examples that we don't know if they
represent all of our data okay maybe we
get good performance but the good
performance will be only on that test
set so if we change and we test or all
of the faults then we can have good good
evaluation and the cross-validation do
you to learn everything from the start
on each fold or do you read to them a
pre trained model not sure I'm following
the question in the cost validation you
have several faults that you said each
fault represent the training at
different step this text at the listing
do if you take a more than train once on
test works on every folder oh do you
take the model that was tested when one
Falls and change it not start from the
beginning and no no you don't change
your mother you take the same model and
recreate random or retrain a
pre-existing model that's the main
question you know you train it from
scratch okay and then you take the mean
between the folds between the test
performance so that's means that you
have several models that you have model
perfect for me
yeah actually you call it a model yeah
okay you have a performance billfold
okay the model is the same you take the
model and you make like a force of the
models might not be the same
yeah but you want to keep the same
parameters because this is what you're
testing your testing these parameters
okay you don't want to change it you're
just making you know how does that
change from the training of the model
but with this well for each
strengthening step for which training
time basically what changes between the
folds or the data okay normally not not
the parameters but the data changes but
that I'm sorry I'm shipping out the
quality system by the way with that
involvement in let's discuss this later
okay
okay models we're talking about models
to models we're going to cover this
these are very basic models the first
one is k9k nearest neighbors this model
basically what it does it take
we're talking as they decide today we're
talking about only about supervised
learning k-nearest neighbors basically
what it does it takes a sample that we
want to predict and it looks around on
the closest the closest samples and
according to the majority of the samples
it determines the class of that sample
we have here blue and we have red dots
okay this is the training the training
set and the yellow one is the one we
need to predict so we take in this case
we talk about the K we take five closest
samples and we see here that the
majority out of the five four are all
red then this is the red that we will
assign the green one
okay basically it's very simple it's
very intuitive okay what is K when you
say K nearest neighbor K is the number
of the closest neighbors that we choose
what would happen if we take a different
case a good question
just with one second if we take three
okay k k is 3 what will we get what
would kind of class still rate okay what
if we take one okay in this case we will
get blue how do we select the k10 for a
lot of scales and - yeah which we try
and you evaluated on there on the tests
on the evaluation set okay now you asked
okay how do we measure
okay what is nearest neighbor what is
near so in machine learning we have many
types of measurement metrics some of
them or two of them are here a Euclidean
is just you know they did stand out
metric it's like you know the Pythagoras
theorem what we started on high school
and then we have for example Manhattan
which caused us to go you know on there
on the lines for example if you go back
to the K nearest points between the
training set and the test set would be
different then you can find very good a
number very good K and it could be
meaningless for the other for the test
set I mean what what you think assume
the dispersity or the characteristic of
those points are pretty much pretty much
the same what happens here it will
answer your question and not in a direct
way what happens in this algorithm that
on the train on the training nothing
happens the algorithm JIT algorithm just
saves and remember the location of the
of the samples okay everything happens
on the test of the own on day on the
evaluation what happens on the
evaluation for each and every sample the
algorithm takes the distance to all of
the samples okay and then it chooses the
decay okay decay that require no each
one of the this new data each sample in
the new data will get its own prediction
but based on the same data set based on
the same training set okay I don't wanna
you know there's a lot of things that we
can say about pausing costs but I will
say only one thing
this relates the point I have just
mentioned this model when you want to
predict it takes a lot of time okay
it takes a lot of time because we need
to measure for every test set all the
distances to the training set to each
one of the training set samples another
basic model is called decision trees
decision trees it's a simple but it's
very important because many other
relevant and popular models like random
forest like boosted trees if you know if
you have heard of like XG boost they use
it basically what happens in this model
is that on each step the model takes a
decision how to separate the data okay
how to cut the data in a way that they
will have full separation what is full
separation or maximal separation it
means that if we separate the data we
get a majority of one class in one one
one side and another class on on the
other side let's state just two extreme
examples if I split the data and I have
let's say I have boys and girls and on
one side I have 100 percent boys and on
the other side I have 100 percent girls
then I can say that this is full
separation and this is very good for the
model because the model can make the
distinction between the classes okay if
I make this separation and I see the
same percentage of boys on that case I
will not be able to learn okay this is
not a good separation so what happens
here okay in this diagram is that on the
first decision point the model takes the
income as the feature to separate with
on the on the t1 and then we can say
that we have the majority of red on the
on the right-hand side and we have the
blue on the left-hand side okay I will
move on because
just to present the basic of course on
each and every decision point then the
algorithm continues to split each and
every branch of the tree okay this can
also be separated in case we have okay
two of the classes on the same side as I
said this is very intuitive and
explainable algorithm and we can learn
multi-class problem with that but it is
[Music]
no it does learn it does learned in the
intercept it will be able because it has
a rule what what the algorithm does in
this case the algorithm creates a set of
rules okay
and then let's say we get we get a
sample okay let's say we get a sample
here so the model ask is income greater
than t1 here no it belongs to this
branch and then the second the second
phase is this decision is it greater
than this line okay the depth or smaller
and then according to the decision
points we get to the location of our
sample then we can make the prediction
okay okay now for the last part of this
presentation before we go into the into
the the practice just talk about a few
metrics only the basic metrics for
classification because there are more
much more metrics than what we present
here the first one is accuracy and we
have this matrix here and I want to
present it in a simple way because the
matrix is simple
but many people also experience one
sometimes you know they tend to confuse
here so we have the columns the columns
relates to the actual what is actual if
the what happens in the in the real
world what happens in the label positive
you know we're going to talk about the
Titanic so positive here a negative
means if they really survived or didn't
survive the people on the Titanic so
everything here both this one this cell
and that cell it's about people who
survived and here it's about people who
did not survive ok this is the actual we
have the predicted ok on the left hand
side that has positive a negative this
relates to our prediction whether we say
if the personal sample survived or not
so what we get here is true positive
through positive we say that it survived
and it actually survived we say the true
negative we say that it did not survive
and it did not survive ok this one are
may be easier false positive and false
negative false positive if you remember
blondes to the negative why is that
because the negative it means that it
did not survive but we said we predicted
it will survive so it's a false about
our prediction ok we had false
prediction we said it was positive and
the false negative it's actually other
way around we say this would be negative
but it actually positive it survived for
those of you come from statistics ok
this is normally you just see actual
this is alpha and this is better ok in
statistics so what is accuracy accuracy
for us the measure accuracy if we take
only the green ones only the samples
that we were correct on divided by the
total samples ok this is a very basic
very basic metric we can see an example
here okay let's say that these are the
samples we have seven seven samples we
have actual actual is the real world
whether they actual actually survived or
not and we have the prediction and here
you can see the false true positive or
negative and so on and on the blue dots
here we can see where we were accurate
whether we were accurate on the positive
or on the negative and we see that we
have four out of seven accurate so this
was the first metric accuracy the other
two metrics are precision and recall
precision so we will start with the
recall recall is the measure the the
metric that takes the real world the
real positives and trying to to take the
percent of how many ways we manage to
detect okay if we have let's say ten
positives okay we're talking about only
about the positives look we have ten
positives and we managed to detect -
okay so we have twenty percent
recall the other one is precision and
precision does not relate to the actual
but relates to the prediction whether or
how many of the samples we were accurate
about so we take the true positive okay
the positive that we were right about
and we divide it by the total prediction
okay and earlier it was true positive
also but divided by the total positive
real positives okay we can see an
example here we have recall we have
precision okay look these are the same
places but
we divided by different numbers because
we have five actual and only four on the
precision yeah each yeah for example
recall when you use the recall when you
want to really detect what it says you
want to detect the the positive for
example okay in the bank you want to
decide whether to give a alone along to
a customer
so you want to detect these you know
suspicious people because you don't mind
to get someone you know who is a you
know you it's someone in between okay
okay you want to get all of them you
don't you don't want to miss anybody you
don't want to not detect someone okay
last thing here is the confusion matrix
confusion matrix takes all of the
classes okay and you have it on the
columns you have it also on the rows
these are the ones that you predicted
this is the true and of course on the
diagonal you get all the accurate or the
now there are all positives for each one
of them is the positive but yeah you get
the day at the true positives okay in
the diagonal and then you can have you
can see here all the ones that you
missed and you can calculate the
precision okay on this axis you can
calculate the recall on that axis this
is something very confusing you see as
it says as they have the names of the
confusion matrix normally it doesn't
normally we need to write whether this
is the actual and this is the the
prediction because sometimes you will
see it the other way around okay so
let's start walking